hockey's a gross sports and you know
there was pressure on an area for our
kids to train and played I've been going
through the Christchurch they've trained
out here in the area there was a ship
with a concrete floor of course that req
req their equipment this facility here
we've modeled that on Olympic standard
state-of-the-art top notch we saw no
point and creating something that wasn't
going to be that way and that's been the
attitude the council's taken as as well
when I'm just going to pop back what we
had we're going to make it better
because we're such a growth area at
least design for the future let's take a
long-term view and so you've got the
regeneration get that's going to go
ahead and copy with river banks is going
on in quiet week we've got facilities
like this it's just a great time to eat
to be part of such a process fantastic
facility you know this is one of the
world's best out there you know it would
be for me it would be great if we had
exceeding around for 20,000 or whatever
but to have a surface like this in the
canopy region is fantastic well who
would have believed it for six years ago
that here we are New Zealand in America
playing in a full international game
here in our district you know we've got
going to have people coming in from from
overseas we're going to have people from
around the country flooding into into
waimakariri to watch an international
everyone's really enjoyed that we've had
so much help it's been so easy coming
down here and we do genuinely enjoy
coming to smaller centres supply because
and as we saw today the crowd really
does get behind us so yes for us
differently it is nice to come to
smaller sinkers and yeah be able to play
in front of the crowd and obviously
we're over in final dress after so it's
nice to get that interaction with them
and here hopefully to inspire them to
want
breakfast Monday you know wearing my
other hat there's a very old time it's
quite relevant that kids who play sports
stay at a court and ninety-eight percent
of the time it's pretty right and so I
want our kids coming down getting out
and about not just talking but you know
the cricket the soccer over the road the
leg be down the road it's going to be a
school cup for the district influent
agree it's really exciting
[Music]